hogwarts legacy fans feel very strongly
about romance
relationships and whether or not it
belongs in the game
so here in today's video we're going to
talk about the problems some people have
with romance potentially
being in the game i'll also give you my
personal thoughts on how i think they
can make it work
by the way people of the internet
retrorecontour here and i'm just a dad
who loves games and the stories
they tell and so by being both a husband
and a dad to young children i have a
unique perspective
on relationships and how i think they
could work in the game and if they
should work in the game
now some of you may be asking what
exactly is the issue here
why are some people having a problem
with this well what you have to
understand here is although many of us
grew up as harry potter fans and are
older more mature now the characters we
interact with at hogwarts will range in
age from 11 to 17 and of course i
realize some of you
fall within that age range as well when
it comes to hogwarts though first years
are 11 when they cross the black lake to
step into hogwarts for the first time
and 7th years finishing out their
schooling are 17 of course
and that's where i think some are
uncomfortable with the idea of
romance options considering it's a
school of underage wizards
and hogwarts legacy were expected to
play as a fifth year and if you look
back at the harry potter books as a
reference point that's really the book
where student romance and relationships
started taking on a more prominent role
actually i guess you could say it even
goes back to goblet of fire with braun's
jealousy of hermione and victor crum but
order of the phoenix took it up another
notch with all the relationship drama
between harry and cho
of course in book six there was even
more with ron and lavender's
relationship harry and jenny and so on
i think where people stand on this
really depends on a couple of things
including things like age your own
maturity level and ultimately
what people mean when they say quote
unquote romance
options now i could be totally wrong
here but i would guess that when most
people think
of romance and relationships in video
games they're probably thinking of the
hyper-sexualized examples like
mass effect or the witcher and for me
when it comes to hogwarts legacy that
particular example has just
not been on my radar at all that's not
what i'm thinking when i say
romance or relationships in hogwarts
legacy so those of us who want romance
and hogwarts legacy are definitely not
talking about something like this and i
don't think it would even come close to
something like what you see in the
witcher believe it or not guys i know
hollywood and tb
try to convince us otherwise but stick
with me here
romantic relationships are about way
more than just
purely physical desires i know hard to
believe right
now i made a video previously about all
the features i'd like to see in hogwarts
legacy and i did list
romance as one of those features for me
it all comes down to doing this in a
tasteful
way that's fitting for the kids in this
age group that would be attending
hogwarts at the time
it also needs to be something true to
the world that it's set in
if we were playing as first years
absolutely not it probably wouldn't have
much of a place in the game
but how could this play out in hogwarts
legacy how could relationships enhance
our experience and even enhance the
gameplay in some ways
what are some tasteful examples of
relationship options that would be
appropriate for 5th year students at
hogwarts so let's take a look here at 5
ways avalanche could feature romance in
a way that would be age appropriate and
fitting for an open world action rpg
number one social links if you look to
games like the persona series you'll
notice they also feature kids and
teenagers that go through relationship
struggles
one relationship component of the
persona series is the social link system
for those who aren't familiar this is a
system where the player decides which
friends they'll spend time with each day
but
like the real world you only have so
much time in a day so this means you
can't spend time with
every single friend and these aren't
just limited to romantic relationships
in fact when it comes to hogwarts legacy
we already know we'll be able to choose
companions to aid us in our journey
throughout the game
so it would make a lot of sense if we
had some sort of social system to track
and build relationships with those
companions along the way
number two special storylines when you
reach a certain point in your
relationship with characters throughout
the game perhaps you could unlock
special storylines and missions that are
only available when you've achieved a
close relationship
whether romantic or platonic these could
be segments focused heavily on teamwork
and camaraderie or maybe even some
lighthearted options like a date to
hogsmeade village
hopefully avalanche is able to give
players a wide range of options for our
companions with multiple fully realized
characters so we can choose best friends
and significant others that
jive best with our own personality or
even just the personality we want to
portray in the game
developing these relationships over the
course of an entire game should only
strengthen moments of heightened tension
in the story i mean just look back at
the harry potter series there are so
many
numerous events that were made all the
more impactful because of how much we
cared about the characters and their
relationships
characters like luna neville sirius
lupin of course the trio i mean
so many characters in harry potter that
we felt close to
and felt close to each other through the
relationships they built throughout the
book
number three gameplay enhancements it's
important to remember that as much as we
want a good story this
is a video game after all and gameplay
is ultimately what will make or break
the experience
going back to persona for a bit the
social link system doesn't just affect
the story
there are clear impacts on gameplay as
well from bonus xp to special skills
certain bonds and relationships will
yield different abilities that can be
used in combat
so let's get wild here for a minute and
really think big about this suppose
you're faced with a stealth mission in
hogwarts legacy and you have
one friend who's really good at potions
who could help you brew polyjuice maybe
but then you have this other friend who
kind of lives on the edge and says that
they could help you steal a teacher's
invisibility cloak
both options would aid you in your
stealth mission but would play out
completely differently depending on
which skill you would develop throughout
the game
through your relationship with those
characters and then you have the whole
spell casting component how certain
characters could be better at charms
whereas others are better at
transfiguration
there's really a ton avalanche could do
here and i hope they go
all in on a system like this number four
social events
extracurricular activities such as club
meetings sporting events or school
dances are
key moments for social interaction we
see a number of these throughout the
harry potter series ranging from the
yule ball to quidditch matches and
something
off the wall like nearly headless nick's
death day party attending
these events with either a significant
other or even multiple members of a
close-knit social group would be another
way
avalanche could place relationships at
the forefront of the game
who knows if there will be anything akin
to a yule wall but that one immediately
jumps to mind as an opportunity
to highlight relationships formed
throughout the school year and could
also set up a big story moment
number five custom dialogue we already
know we'll be able to make choices
throughout the game and i think that
should apply to our relationships as
well
by building stronger bonds with our
fellow students at hogwarts we should
unlock special dialogue options that are
only available to close friends or
significant others
this is a small element but one i really
think would help make the world feel
more real and more alive
i mean let's be honest there are certain
people in our own lives who we would
tell certain things and then other
friends where we wouldn't tell them the
same thing
even if we consider them both to be
friends we even see this in the books
when hermione and jenny begin to open up
to one another about their romantic
relationships and we learn about
conversations
after the fact that harry and ron aren't
privy to in the moment this is simply
because hermione doesn't want to open up
with them
on some of those details now i'm curious
if any of you guys out there have tried
out harry potter hogwarts mystery i
remember downloading it when it first
came out played it for a little bit
wasn't really my cup of tea so i moved
on
but it's still a game that they are
pushing out new content for and back
around february they did a special
valentine's day
event again i didn't play it very long
so i don't know how it works but you can
see the trailer playing right now where
they actually had
a specific emphasis on romance so i'm
curious to how they handled it in that
game if any of you know be sure and let
me know down in the comments below maybe
i need to give it another shot try it
out see how things have changed
of course there's also that harry potter
magic awakened game which
i haven't had a chance to try out yet
i'm in the us if any of you have played
that one i don't know if it has a
romance segment or not but that might be
worth looking into as well
i know several of you have been asking
about that one in the comments i really
hope it comes to the us
soon so we can all get a chance to try
it out i haven't played it so i can't
say
exactly how it all works but clearly
between games like this and persona
there is a precedent here for romance
and relationships being
in games that feature underage teenagers
of course i want to hear what you guys
think as well did i sway any of you who
are maybe on the fence about whether or
not this can work or maybe i pushed you
the other way and you don't want this in
the game at all now
either way thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon